Diese Schuhe sind aus Stein:
Anstelle von Leder ist an vielen Stellen
elastischer Schiefer verarbeitet.
Produziert hat sie das nachhaltige Luxuslabel
„nat-2“ aus München.
Sebastian Thies leitet die
innovationsfreudige Sneaker-Schmiede.
Seine Familie stellt
seit sechs Generationen Schuhe her,
doch Stein ist auch für ihn
ein völlig neues Material.
Es ist hunderte Millionen Jahre alt,
also wirklich ein Naturprodukt.
Jedes Paar Schuhe ist ein Unikat.
Rein technisch gesehen
gibt’s jetzt keinen Vorteil zu Leder,
weil die Schuhe sind schon
teilweise etwas fragiler.
Also, jetzt in Sibirien bei minus 40 Grad
wird das schon etwas schwieriger,
aber so im Alltag
absolut alltagstauglich und tragbar.
Doch wie wird der Stein so flexibel, dass er für
einen Schuh genutzt werden kann?
Ausgangsmaterial sind riesige Blöcke
Marmor oder Schiefer.
Mit einer speziellen Methode werden daraus
millimeterdünne Platten.
Der Clou:
ein elastisches Trägermaterial,
das mit dem Stein verklebt wird.
Eine Erfindung
des Berliner Unternehmens „Roxxlyn“.
Die Flexibilität des Steines
erreicht man eigentlich,
indem man ihn ganz,
ganz dünn gestaltet –
wir sind im Bereich unter einem Millimeter –
und verbinden diesen Stein
mit was Stabilem sozusagen.
Wir verwenden dort
unterschiedliche Trägermaterialien
wie Fiberglas oder ‘nen Baumwollvlies,
was sozusagen dem Stein die Stabilität gibt,
dass die einzelnen Steinpartikel
auch bei Biegungen sozusagen
zusammengehalten werden.
Durch ein geheimes Verfahren,
bei dem der Stein im Wechsel
Hitze und Kälte ausgesetzt wird,
bekommt er seine endgültige Flexibilität –
und kann sogar vernäht werden.
Neben den Schuhen gibt es auch Gürtel,
Sonnenbrillen
oder Taschen aus Stein.
Doch der Einsatz des Materials in der Mode
hat auch seine Grenzen.
Es ist schwierig, Stein jetzt als zum Beispiel
T-Shirt oder Jacke oder sowas zu tragen.
Also, auch dort haben wir schon
Experimente gemacht,
aber Atmungsaktivität und
Beweglichkeit ist eben
nicht so gegeben wie bei anderen Materialien.
Es wird weiterhin kostspielig
und aufwendig bleiben
und daher eher ‘ne Nische
als den Massenmarkt bedienen.
Eine Nische hat sich
auch Sebastian Thies gesucht.
Für seine Schuhe experimentiert er immer
wieder mit ausgefallenen Materialien
wie Leder aus „Zunderschwamm“ –
einem Baumpilz –
oder mit Stroh von Wiesen
aus Bayern und Österreich.
Aber auch Kaffee,
Milch,
Holz
oder Fischleder
haben schon als Material
für seine Sneaker gedient.
Mein Vater hat in den 90ern den ersten
kompostierbaren Schuh entwickelt
und deshalb sind wir
bei diesem Thema Naturmaterialien
eigentlich schon immer im Thema gewesen.
Und heutzutage passiert da halt sehr viel,
weil natürlich das Bewusstsein
der Leute größer wird.
Und deshalb gibt’s auch
mehr Innovationen in dem Bereich.
Echtgummi-Sohlen, pflanzlich gegerbtes
Leder, Innensohlen aus Kork –
auch die unauffälligeren Teile seiner Schuhe
sind größtenteils natürlich.
Für uns ist Nachhaltigkeit
erstens ‘ne Selbstverständlichkeit,
also nicht unbedingt dieses Modethema,
wie es oft in den Medien
im Moment propagiert wird,
sondern es ist einfach für uns:
Ein hochwertiges oder auch Luxus-Produkt ist
keines, wenn es nicht nachhaltig ist.
Mit seinen Schuhen aus Stein
geht Sebastian Thies
seinen innovativen Weg konsequent weiter.